document drama the discovery of five
additional Pages marked classified at
President Biden's home in Delaware the
president did not address that situation
yesterday during a visit to the Ebenezer
Baptist Church in Atlanta and the White
House said on Saturday that this latest
batch was discovered on Thursday around
20 potentially classified records have
been found at locations associated with
the president for those keeping count
Adriana Diaz who first broke this story
got everyone to pay attention last
Monday is in Washington again with the
latest Adriana good morning Good morning
Tony President Biden is facing a growing
storm of criticism for his handling of
classified materials Republican
lawmakers are ramping up for
investigations and one Democratic
senator is even calling the situation
embarrassing
and made growing calls for transparency
the chair of the house oversight
committee which is investigating the
documents matter sent this letter to the
White House Sunday requesting the
visitor log of President Biden's
Wilmington Delaware home from his first
day as president to now the
administration hasn't been transparent
about what's going on with President
Biden's possession of classified
documents classified documents for Mr
Biden's time as vice president ended up
at his Wilmington home and former
private office the original discovery
made in November was not disclosed to
the public until CBS News asked the
White House about it one week ago and a
new revelation came Saturday when White
House lawyer Richard Sauber said when he
went to the president's Delaware home to
turn over a single page marked
classified to the justice department
Five additional pages with
classification markings were discovered
among the material well it's certainly
embarrassing right I mean it's
embarrassing that you would find a small
number of documents certainly not on
purpose purpose Democrats say there are
key differences between President
Biden's situation and the hundreds of
classified documents found at Mar-A-Lago
which former president Trump resisted
turning over for more than a year the
moment they found out about the
documents that day turned them over that
is a very different posture than what we
saw with Donald Trump but while some
Republicans allege a double standard
what's real concerning to me is how
Justice is applied and is it applied
equally others say this presents
problems for both parties so I think
there's blame to go around to both sides
of this and I think if you're an honest
Statesman you just can't point the
fingers to the other guy and deny that
there was problems on our side as well
the special counsel appointed by the
Attorney General to investigate will
soon get to work compiling his team and
digging deeper to determine the key
question was it simply carelessness or
was it intentional legal experts tell us
that only if this was intentional could
potential charges be warranted Gail
all right Adriana thank you so much for